what do humans some primates some bats
the spiny Mouse and the elephant shrew
have in common they all get periods
I'm Gabriella contarudis and I'm
studying for my doctorate at the
University of Oxford and I am fascinated
about menstrual cycles menstruation is a
natural process that affects half of the
world's population during their lives
but it's little understood so here's
five things you probably didn't know
about periods
births are myth busting
Moon sinking is not a thing it's such a
compelling idea the idea that menstrual
cycles sync up with the cyclical waxing
and waning of the Moon much like the
ocean tides the moon cycle is 29.5 days
but in 2019 an analysis of 7.5 million
menstrual cycles from 1.5 million women
around the world found no relationship
at all another commonly held view is
that when people live together their
periods sync up humans love to find
patterns and a certain amount of overlap
is to be expected but the actual sinking
of Cycles is not backed by data the
textbook idea of a 28-day cycle is a bit
of a myth too a normal cycle can be
anything up to seven days longer or
shorter than this everyone is unique
hormones can be powerful in a good way
okay let's talk about estrogen
it's an incredible hormone that we're
only just starting to understand there's
a specific type of estrogen that's made
in the ovaries called estradiol this is
released throughout the menstrual cycle
and it Peaks just around ovulation
research suggests estrogen can have some
powerful effects in 2021 neuroscientists
at the University of California Santa
Barbara for the first time tracked a
woman's hormones throughout the cycle
and looked at whether these had any
impact on the brain they found an
increase in connectivity throughout the
brain at times when estrogen was high
one theory is that estrogen causes our
neurons to form new connections to other
neurons which helps with learning and
memory
98 of mammals don't periods lots of
animals do have reproductive Cycles like
cats and elephants but they reabsorb the
lining of the womb rather than shedding
it as a period so why do humans
menstruate the truth is we don't know
one Theory put forward by evolutionary
geneticist Dina Emira is that it's a tug
of war of energy between the mother and
baby human embryo is very deep into the
lining of the womb which gives them more
access to nutrients from the mother's
body so the lining of the womb builds up
nice and thick each month to create a
shield to protect the mother this thick
lining also makes it easier to shed so
she doesn't expend a huge amount of
energy if a fetus won't ultimately make
it
the ancient Greeks
the wandered
and as it floated around they believe
this wandering womb caused all sorts of
diseases bizarre as it sounds this idea
stuck around for centuries and so did
the idea of Hysteria the kind of
catch-all pseudo-medical term which was
used to undermine women
in 1931 a new town was coined PMT or
premenstrual tension This was later
renamed premenstrual syndrome or PMs and
refers to any symptoms experienced in
the week before the start of a period
some argue the term syndrome is not
useful and it would be more accurate to
refer to premenstrual symptoms
BMS might be linked to inflammation why
do women experience premenstrual
symptoms it could be down to
inflammation
inflammation is the body's way of
protecting itself from infection and
just as our hormone levels change during
a menstrual cycle so do levels of
inflammation and ovulation part of our
immune system is temporarily suppressed
a little that's a refertilized egg if
there is one can implant itself without
getting rejected while inflammation is a
sign of a strong immune system too much
inflammation is bad symptoms include
headaches tiredness changes in appetite
sounds a bit like PMS doesn't it some
have suggested is this rise in
inflammation in the second half of the
cycle that's actually behind what we
call PMS so that's a quick rundown of a
few facts myths and theories about
periods and still there's so much
Unknown about something that happens to
half of the world's population at some
point in their life but that's exciting
because it means there is so much more
to discover
thanks for watching if you if you
enjoyed that be sure to check out these
videos next and if you haven't already
hit the Subscribe button and click the
Bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video